here's what would happen if the  strongest hurricane ever hit new york  a hurricane what if would start as a  tropical storm in the caribbean and  slowly climb from a category one to a  five and even up to a six the storm  would be larger in size than half of the  us  storm surges over eight meters high  would cause rapid and dangerous flooding  all over the city without mass  evacuations millions will be stranded or  in immediate danger of drowning  powerful winds would make flying debris  a constant hazard especially shards of  glass from damaged skyscrapers that  would sway in the wind like trees  all the power would go out too all of  new york city and its nearly 9 million  residents would be in total darkness  vital services such as health care  transportation and communication would  be completely cut off  millions would lose their homes and many  would die because